well joining me now is the former
Conservative MP now a member of the
independent group Anna Sabri welcome to
you
what's your feeling do you think that
this meaningful vote is like to be
postponed I don't see how she can for
goodness sakes this delay and this
dithering has just got to stop and she
gave her word at the despatch box that
she would come back and we would make
proper progress this week those were
promises made and they must be delivered
on but wouldn't it be sensible to find a
proposal that has got the majority
support of the house oh I don't disagree
with you about that and that's why
tomorrow
certainly the group that I'm now a
member of will be putting down our own
amendment absolutely to drive forward a
process and I know others agree with it
I'm not saying it'll get selected or
voted on there are others who have taken
the same view that we must do everything
we can one to avoid No Deal and secondly
to make proper progress so we need votes
in Parliament to see where there is a
consensus from my point of view whatever
we come up with I want it then to go to
the people for them to determine the
future you see that I mean this is part
of problem is there because you want
another vote another referendum but I
want the best way to get it is to break
to break this process the thing I
actually more concerned about at the
moment is making sure that we get no
deal absolutely off the table and it is
to the eternal shame of this government
they've not done that especially when
the house actually voted in favor of us
removing No Deal as an option and the
house was very clear on that it was
actually more clear on that than it was
on the so-called Brady amendment Mrs May
chooses to follow Brady and ignores that
vote which is as I say to the eternal
shame of a government that's meant to
believe in business and it's not just
your viewers of course who are crying
out for certainty and leadership British
businesses as well and they are being
profoundly let down well except you know
you say that crying out for certainty
and leadership but the one thing that we
know for sure another vote would do is
prolong the uncertainty what would
people's vote yeah
not at all right if you had a people's
vote you would know because you would
know that that's where you were moving
to and I think it's quite interesting
that yesterday Jeremy Hunt
if we leave in
days time we'll know where we are as
well and that'll be a lot quicker but
that would be a fee for our country and
the words of the brexit sorry in the
business secretary it would be ruinous
for our country but a people's mode
absolutely would begin to provide the
certainty that we absolutely need we're
going Jeremy Hunt yesterday conceded the
reason he doesn't want a people's vote
is he thinks that people would vote
remain so people need to understand that
the only reason the government doesn't
want a second referendum is because they
think people they are prepared to take
us out of the European Union in the
knowledge that on their own admission
the majority of people have now to come
to the view that the best deal we have
is the current deal we know I agree but
that's but that was the logic of his
stance yesterday we choose Michael Gove
today which is that you need a
compromise that the majority did vote to
leave but the manner of that leaving
should take account no I think the
mistake that is being lost and made in
all of this is that it is absolutely
right and it is the case that 52% of
those that voted voted for us to leave
the European Union two and a half years
ago and over the time we've seen two
things I would argue first of all you
can't actually do brexit you certainly
can't do it and be true to the Good
Friday Agreement and people are entitled
you can't actually do brexit in the
sense that if you leave both in in
Theresa Mays terms how red lines I
haven't made you leave the single market
and the customs union then you will
breach the Good Friday Agreement because
some that basis you return to the hard
border in Northern Ireland so that's
what you mean you don't mean that it's I
don't think you can do back so i mean
whichever way you cut it you you are in
a position where by the government's own
assessments and this is a brexit
government show that the people at this
country will have their future
prosperity reduced that bears on MPs
Minds I mean can you think of anything
else where you knowingly vote for
something knowing it will make you I
mean the problem with that argument
you know I was there in Brussels in
December is that the European Union the
27 and the UK have agreed withdrawal
agreement which they say delivers brings
it well it delivers a form of exit what
he actually does is as you know only
deals with the divorce settlement and if
viewers at home are fed up with the last
two and a half years they need to know
that the whole matter is far from over
even if we accept Mrs May so-called deal
because there is no deal about our
future relationship that has yet to be
determined and it means that we face the
prospect of years of more uncertainty
more rouse and more chaos as we try to
wrestle and that's why I think it would
be better now we know the reality of
exit get it back to the British people
they are entitled to change now you say
the worst option would be if we left in
eighteen days time without a deal yes
that is currently what parliament has
voted for in inactivating article 50
isn't it No so how can it legally be
stopped this is that this we have to
change the law but in any event we can
ask for an extension but can we be very
clear about this when people voted for
that date to go into the withdrawal act
it was on the racist it's really
important at him it was on the basis
that that promise from the leaf campaign
that we would secure a deal about our
future trade and security arrangements
would be settled by the end of March
that is what Theresa May promised in her
speech and that has changed because that
deal is far from being sort of at the
point I want to ask you as a legislator
as a member of parliament is what it
would require to stop Britain leaving
with no deal because the truth is the
votes as envisaged wouldn't do that they
were late well then you'd have an
extension after the meaningful vote the
Parliament as you say has already voted
once for No Deal but that didn't have
any legal force so what would it
actually require could have done if the
Prime Minister had been good enough it -
to respect the will of Parliament but
moving on as you say so there are two
things that could ignore the will of
parliament again that's
exactly with 18 days to go she can if
she accepted the will of Parliament she
can't ask one of her ministers as their
legislation allows so that March the
29th is not activated as the trigger
date it may be that we have to go so far
as to put into legislation the removal
of the date from the withdrawal act but
there are other ways as I say within the
act it allows the minister responsible
Minister not to trigger on the 29th of
an extension delay and she accepts
because they're longer you delay the in
Parliament putting anything for part
that less likely is that there's going
to be time to do it out of time anyway
we haven't even started on the
legislation as you know even if mrs.
Mays deal goes through which is
obviously very unlikely we would still
have to put it into legislation in order
for it to become a treaty and that is
simply not it's not me it's the
government that knows that trouble is
with Teresa unless we leave without a
deal exactly which is what I'm saying
pass the clock but the majority of
members of parliament the majority of
people in our country do not want you
here and they stop it they may not want
it you stop it
yeah because first of all we can vote
for an extension and secondly we can
mandate the minister to remember to not
to trigger on the 29th of March those
are facts there's within the legislation
it's within that withdrawal Act the idea
that we can't stop No Deal of course we
can stop it where there's a will there's
a way this this government listen to you
it's possible that this government is
playing hardball and it's running down
no I think the Prime Minister is let's
be very clear about that we know there
are a substantial number of Ministers we
heard one only last night saying that
they will not sit by and allow our
country to crash out without a deal they
now to have the courage of their
convictions and if they need to leave
their ministerial office they must do it
and that's another hard blackmail game
that this Prime Minister is playing and
it is wrong and we will only do the
right thing by our country when people
put their own ambitions and their
political power
second and put the national interest
first and that's what must happen along
with leadership to lead people after
this dreadful brexit meds okay Alice
Avery thank you very much indeed